which talk-show hosts or DJs are people
that you admire were some of the
people's careers that you'd like to
emulate I remember one day having a
conversation for the guy who worked in
imaging down the hall for me and he
ended up creating his own business from
day one he was very supportive of my
goals in radio and he said your job is
not to become the next let's say roughly
mob or the next how we're starting your
job is to be the first been crack so I
never really focused a lot on who I want
to be like there was people whose
careers I respected whose talent I
respected I mean but Flynn law for one
enormous ly successful very good it is
craft knows how to manipulate the
audience in a way that he wants he knows
how to sell the show and he knows how to
make it profitable that's the business
of radio another guy Howard Stern you
know whether or not you love him or you
hate him he found his audience and he
knew how to exploit it and then on a
smaller scale I remember one day a
friend might call me up and saying you
gotta listen to this dude I didn't
realize you have a long-lost father out
there his name was Tom Lycus and I was
just saying Tom and I just thought it
was hysterical and even though
politically I may not have agreed with
my everything his ability tough he honed
down who was audience was it was a very
brave girl you know he had 17 to 25 year
old frustrated young men and he just
exploited the hell happened and he
really was successful so I I respected
their ability to be able to identify
their audience and be successful with it
those are two examples and other guys
Phil Henry he's a master of theater
radio back in the golden years or tell
me he have the silver screen in radio I
don't know
golden era but there was a lot of radio
theater and that's been lost it's all
about liners it's all about you know
fitting this cookie cutter how many you
know ears can we fill with this certain
message and that fits in that block and
and we're going to fit this block and
it's all done by bean counters now but
back then it was about theater of the
mind it's all about creating an
experience to help people escape this
before television and Phil Henry had
this unique ability to kind of create
this fictitious world he was the guest
he was the host I never seen a guy more
talented than that yeah on the fly he
would be to fake characters plus himself
while having a caller try to try to
argue with his fake guest and it just
watching it was was a lot of fun so I'd
say he's one of the most talented people
that I've ever met but there's a lot of
great talent out there it's just
different genres those are some of the
people
you